five for Bob no because he's gonna dance
through the whole thing got it Bobby
steel do you want me to dance well I
just wanted you overexert yourself all
right
okay let's do it all right let's do it
again good good okay don't [ __ ] around
man
I love you now listen guys welcome to
another episode of tiger belly I'm your
I'm a good guy I feel I believe that I
really believe I'm a good guy you know
what I go to when I was in San Antonio I
met a lot of these like you know my
little beautiful frijoles is what I call
them you know you not the refri these
[ __ ] already fried up you know man
but these Mexican people and these
people that come to the shows they go
hey bro I go what's up [ __ ] what's up
bro
I go hey I think we love you do like
Thank You gracias amigo the COS III feel
the same I love them too and there's
some whites one block I met it was
beautiful but San Antonio thank you for
coming out I made more money there than
I've ever made and this is building and
that's called me living a fantasy [ __ ]
whole life mmm and I love it I love
loose [ __ ] all right John rewind rewind
do you love tight [ __ ] yeah cuz I'm a
Christian and like I like any [ __ ] that
hasn't been touched
unless the Lord anyway it's good to be
here
Tiger belly we got John - look at that
look at this flat faced flat faced
fellow flat faced fella
oh he can't be the president cuz he was
on a coin it'll only look like a line
right because your face
we got the worst you bro I know but you
bro dude you're like where the I've been
I've been researching white people and
you're the worst of them but yours too
the best and you know what you're white
the woman that Asian woman that you're
with you know I've been making fun of
her last couple of months because you
had manner oh yeah
I'm telling you right now I'm my new
goal now is to get her to leave him I
believe I truly believe okay mom and
says she's way too good for him not only
that she's know he shown this he just
shot you're gonna be doing this with
your own dick in your hand because she's
gonna be gone no I love you though
things I don't know what's wrong with me
when I when I don't know I have this you
when I look at you I want to [ __ ]
love you too
so weird anyway and then we got kill you
good I'm gonna how's pilot season pretty
good great hasn't started you're gonna
get something thank you
but I want to say something we have a
great guest today and I'm gonna do a
little back story about this guest on
there are certain things that I didn't
know about the human condition or human
beings before I met this person
and the things that I didn't know is
that I didn't know that a human being
human being could talk without lips so
when a minimal like oh you can the lips
aren't you know yeah you know it's not a
vital you know it's a vocal whatever I'm
not uh you know me I'm not a facial
doctor not sure there's doctors
specifically for the face that I don't
know and then I didn't know that you
could take a couple of my friends told
me you want to make up a doll of this
next comic I go I don't know you can
make a doll out of them you can't make a
fire create a fire throw this raggedy
and and in there and after you do it the
fire right you take all the that's
that's the doll that's the doll he looks
like if Alabama had at renoble incident
you mean like if true noble happened in
Alabama then you'd be like oh I get
why this [ __ ] guy looks like a
[ __ ] Muppet all right no don't say
nothing but we here's that's that's the
negative new here's the positive okay
okay um I'm sorry but I'm sorry brought
pot you know when I saw this guy inform
for the first time this way before he
was on a show called Last Comic Standing
and all that stuff before he got any
that disaster movie I like the storm
when the redneck he was in the rent at
that movie too right you watched that
one a lot I loved that one
yeah I love that movie and I love you in
it I'm so jealous of you but anyway so
um he's so funny
um he's lipless he's redheaded all the
negative things you know but like you
know how like you know when you know
when Chris you know Chris Vaughn xenca
is yeah so in in Colorado
what does he hugs you could talk now
okay what is Chris friend seca have he
has like tiny arms maybe but he's a
wheelchair right oh yeah yeah I just was
trying to guess what it was with what
yeah but he the wheelchair but he took
his handicap and they turned a negative
into a positive which is what we both
did I think I think so right because I
think that you and I are both yes mrs.
mythological in that way I agree